do you find yourself if you're friends
with people and you know that they have
pretty big issues with other people
because I I like the no jumper thing is
like I mean when when [ __ ] Mack was
coming up there a lot with Tyrell being
in the building it was just like I was
like yo that [ __ ] that shit's crazy like
this guy's got whatever he's got
tattooed on his [ __ ] forehead it's
Hero's a main host there like it just it
was crazy do you find yourself like
turning down [ __ ] or not being a part of
certain [ __ ] maybe because of the
relationships you have outside of being
a host I mean loyalty is always going to
be number one in my book before anything
like I don't care about
[ __ ] like that but you know Tyrell has
grown enough and he doesn't care do you
feel me if you know if if [ __ ] Mack
wasn't how he is Tyrell probably
wouldn't have no problem sitting down
with him he sat down with odm Slim Right
and I thought that that was super big
for the culture in the street today
yeah like [ __ ] like that is super dope
so Tyrell has it to where he's looking
at the bigger picture of where he wants
to be placed in in his history and CMAC
is just c-mac you feel me he stands on
this [ __ ] he you know he is he is who he
is and that's why people love him so I
mean situations like that are always
going to conflict and I don't get in the
middle of that but loyalty wise like I
got a rock with my with my guys right or
wrong yeah have you turned down an
interview because you just kind of knew
maybe somebody you're friend with might
feel some type of way
um not turned down the interview I just
don't be there right I was just like hey
if somebody else wouldn't do it y'all
can do it I'm not gonna be a part of it
yeah
yeah like that's like right now you my
guy right I [ __ ] with you I can't
somebody that that blatantly hates you
you feel me like or or is this super
going crazy on you I can't sit there and
call you my friend and go sit down with
him or facilitate something knowing that
he's about to say something bad about
you right I'll be a fake ass [ __ ] for
that that's fair